Andthen
[Music]
the audio and cancer to be the best way to
Bet on Young people Special Edition
Android os at Once we have Band School
I believe that what can really make a
difference is  to bet on
targeted qualifications aimed at these young
people, in fact that a great tool for
entering the job market is the measures
they are designed to take Faced with
this unemployment that has been increasing
and that has made many young people victims
of these successive crises without the n  for
certainty I to make sure that the
Clinical at joking high must be
grateful and the strains and all of you and
call on Me that's the best way out of
this World Is to change permissions and
i just lay the commission on Reading
stream program with Cold  as You
implement Security
o William o is at Wilson And locate and
to be and Rose to put you in playing on
[Music]
and how can the european union in this case
say The european parliament and the council
of the european union  reach a consensus
regarding the European minimum wage
given the economic differences between
countries, between mentalities and even
between the formats for applying
national minimum wages in each
state, but the objective of this
directive is above all to create a
reference that is a reference for
this path of convergence of a
percentage on what should be the
guarantee that we all have a
decent salary wherever we are in Europe
and that we go ahead of them stays
using people I gave the truth DF asks you don't
understand law student Market has a
lot  what we have books we have a
Security in the Life of the future from
family And I take it heart is Living out
of the work and sentences in Floripa
the programs that the European Union is
thinking of implementing for young people in terms
of social assistance  for those who
most Franco A rewards namely
the homeless and people with
very low social income Our
Total priority in this  at the moment in a bit the
financial instruments that we have
essentially one for completing
qualifications and training courses
for namely in the strategic areas
that we are just talking about whether in
digital or in environmental areas and
opinioni de raza for this Cold fear the
most deprived people  to Help The Christ
to support the food is also
helping the trammps Where to find out
just impose their service so This is
something
and a Demon and Simone particularly
important in the ceremony is on your
phone Will Young People Like a young
people with disability is  the European
commission has proposed strategy to Help
people with disabilities and Without You
the dimension of the
social state also in what is health and
the answers to health questions  rias
I think it was very interesting to receive
these this this evaluation of the
concerns more see less at this
moment that young people feel and
that go very much in line with what is the
discussion that will take place in the
official cemeru of the port o wrapping take care
and we work hard with you no  Golden
Globe in Generations and identify your
to you with me
[Music]